so okay so h4 I'll play g4 9 h 2 h 5
probably g3 maybe up 3 something like
that so unlike past dreams you guys I'm
actually gonna I'm probably gonna be
listening to music on my phone since I
think my microphones or my headphones or
Bluetooth or whatever kind of screwed it
up so I'm gonna be doing a bit of a bit
of a mix this time and I know you guys
actually that was on me like the
disconnection last time was accidentally
streaming to another channel to San
climb so night f1 g3 so I mean I don't
know if who wants to go Bishop chief
five or Bishop h6 or what he's trying to
play for
so he goes Bishop h6 Oakland 85 probably
takes takes maybe 93 Knight a5 idea so
I'll play Bishop CA to take care of five
five squares efficiency - I'll play a 5
B 3 play 97 I don't really want him to
get night at 5 where you can capture the
pawn attack my narrator and she took
something maybe of Queen g5 so do I play
a 5 or not oh let's see hmm don't have
to don't I really don't have to play a 5
but I kind of want to see if there's
some other idea that I have here um I
don't go f5 what else do I have though I
don't see it so I'm going to play off 5
so b4 I'm gonna take I'll take I'm gonna
play 94 I'll take I'll take
94 I can play night of five now with the
idea of going that 84 Knight f3 if I got
the chance I'll take I'll take with the
bishop and my Bishop also covers the
very important east X square here so he
doesn't have any kind of tricks I'm just
gonna play Queen f6 develop the Queen
put pressure on f2 maybe long term store
okay one let's play rook e8 r okay seven
I'll go rookie rookie sobbing just
protect the pawn and now everything's
very compact over here I've got the
Queen the rooks the Knights so we need
three I could play E 4 which is
interesting I'm gonna I'm gonna go for
it just because now it's night his box
so he never has 94 ideas c5 I'll take
takes so it wants to take on d6 so I'm
gonna play rook e8 just over protect you
for also protect the work on e7 so I can
capture with the pawn again see one
wants to take and go over to c7 maybe
always there um let's see it's gonna
play King g8 get out of the way of any
tricks and then tonight e6 also it's not
a check anymore I might add so this is
looking better
so we're c7 so he obviously wants to try
and do something along the seventh rank
it looks like now I do
no no Queen f3 is no goods by t-taking
play like queenie 5 or rookie 5 maybe or
just rookie 7 a lot of a lot of
possibilities here um when you find 96
could be recent troubles so rookie 7 I
think I want to play workpiece oven here
and if he checks let's go King G 796
teenage sovereign I should be safe
although he's rook f8 which are work f8
workouts oven maybe
oh wait am i waiting on time something
how am i down on times only am i lagging
or and he just wondered uh some pieces
so I'm gonna have to blitz here so I'm
not gonna be making any comment or if
the next ten seconds you guys oh I love
ya night Wow okay you missed it though
yeah what's with the lags i lagging
there or was that just me being slow
okay that was we're gonna be really fast
this time so now it's finite element
suddenly I wasn't fine on time so I
don't have to be really fast this game
b6 okay interesting smells quit bishops
III know okay - tricks now and
everything's pretty solid now play King
up to a fish bus six I'll go KJ three so
I'll play Bishop d3 now or b3 probably
just busy too
day three
there should be - okay - I'll go Bishop
b3 or if it should be one this even
better actually
let's see okay so he's trying to play
work be three just move my bishop away
maybe or I can play even e4 I'll play E
for just to see what he how he wants to
respond three e5 this Bishop e7 well
it's their work c2 and I'll put my other
work on CY actually my bishop on e 2 is
not ideally place I'm gonna remove that
back and then I'm gonna play Bishop b4
or okay one next move about there should
be two maybe okay two bishops they
wanted their b2r okay one also as
possible um like this hopefully okay one
wonder this tactic but it's still
probably okay except night on d7 is so
bad that he doesn't really have many
square is 4 K 7 B 8 I can play queen g5
or maybe even Queen h6 here I play Queen
age sex with the idea of Bishop takes g6
next with maybe Queen g5 is always the
move here I don't know if it's good I'll
go Forks I want to try and win this game
TG 7 now if I take he's still okay so
let's see so if I take and Playworks e7
maybe seven now I'm gonna put the
fishpond c2 so I can go fish before and
now he's really tied down so let's let's
see so King out for
play rugby seven just to Bishop c2 and
now I'm threatening Bishop takes g6 so
this is perfect now he's gonna have to
move the king and then I get King off
sex or King h6 maybe I could even maybe
take but that feels too superficial so
I'm just gonna keep on waiting here
Bishop d3 now there's no square Ronnie
six for the night so I'll put the roof
on c7 attack the pawn to c6 King f8 just
gonna play out for keep on keep on
improving the pawn structure now he
blonder now I can just take and I can I
could take I could play rook c8 no
actually I can't play Rocio so I'm gonna
take and play push page 5 kg 4 and all
the more important thing here is all his
pawns are on light squares so he can't
can't really do much because the bishop
here is so much better than the night so
I'm gonna put the fish 1 e 2 no now I'm
just gonna bring the King all the way
around to a5 and it should be just be
so you guys said you're hearing the the
noise in the background that's just my
my mouse making noises so let's see who
else wants to play oh I'll play I'll
play Tanya a few games see what he has
in store okay places okay so I'm gonna
be basically worse out of the opening
depending what he does
here's 95 but I can take on b3 and go
king king d7 maybe okay so does 295 so I
can take and play King d7 maybe or King
d8 I don't know which one's better hard
to tell
I'm gonna go King g7 I fished before I'm
gonna play knight c6 so we'll see
all right have fish about three maybe
his wall probably I should take first
one play knight c6 and see what he wants
to do I guess he doesn't know 97 IV 5 so
you can't quite play Knight see sobbing
um so your takes eliminates the
aesthetics of knights to 7 hopefully
work scene eight fish page three
probably f5 probably or just e six in d5
94 maybe King T it was better in
retrospect because now I won't have Bush
page three Chuck but mostly
it should be five now I take on d4
blenny as rook d1 if I take on c7 or
maybe a six as possible as well let's
see so I'm gonna play a six probably
he'll take on c6 and I'll take back with
the king
so I see something someone just said
I've got the best hats the loudest music
and the oranges paints
let's look that's a it's a good one 95
I'll play Bishop takes d4 maybe I don't
see a reason this doesn't work so I'll
try to get away with it
Bishop e5 if I take rook suit 1 yeah
I've got some problems here to deal with
so he'll probably check I'll play King
d6 takes Knight h6 takes takes I'm
obviously much worse here but b2 is
hanging his pawn structure is not really
ideal for Bishop e5
hmm my seven cakes takes 96
so he goes work d5 so if I go King e6 d3
and play like ah see he wants to go to
night-night c5 or Knight b6 okay there's
a d6 just to cut that off
Knight b6 maybe 95 96 and I mean I'm
still obviously worse but I won say I'm
more so point where it's clearly lost
still so we'll see so please work d3 so
I can play b5 maybe ain't got well why
not play a 5 stop any be four tricks c3
can do six
okay so please each six just figure out
exactly what I'm trying to do here I'm
just gonna wait with King c64 tanks play
out three at 186 play 94 I'll just play
Knight d4 here gauge five I think I'm
gonna play f3 which about four Hertz g7
I can just take so here is he's
basically we're basically blitzing
against the clock so okay so he wants a
draw so he just takes the draw stuff
okay decent start considering how lost I
was that last game it's not a big deal
so I'll Castle probably hopefully 85
maybe not
he castles play d4 this would be six
maybe or Bishop d7 just be three there
should be three and pretty pretty
standard kind of setup here I just want
to go through g5 which I will do right
now so if he takes I'll take if you take
so I'll take on a one so let's sleep so
it takes on e4 so you take with a knight
or with the pawn I'm gonna take with a
knight he'll play 97 obviously d4 h6 not
not so it's so great so I kind of want
to try to find a way to sack some
material here so I play Knight c3 h6
Bishop age for which I think is what I'm
gonna do then I'm gonna stack on g5 so
like Vigo's HSN special page for g5 all
the sack
I mean I think it's very likely he'll do
it or hold trade first one play it but
pretty sure that he's gonna play g5
so just sorry you guys I'm also kind of
Daniel is a pretty decent player so I
have to take this a bit seriously which
is why I haven't been responding to any
comments in the chat so Queenie eight so
tonight at nine of five is interesting
cleanup three is also quite reasonable
here which is what I'm gonna do so you
have to move the night so he's gonna go
night h7 I'm gonna go bish page six most
likely the 95 I also fish page six so
pretty much regardless of what he
doesn't probably playing Bishop h6 here
so he goes e4 I think I can just take
though and Queenie five min ago Bishop
h6 anyway probably rook e8 I mean he can
take on b4 but he's gonna go rook e8 now
he's not trying to take take the pawn on
e4 so I'm gonna go rip d1 cuz the ephors
not hanging because I have a double
threat on a sudden take stakes so it
goes Knight of fate so to find some way
to Rio reactivate my pieces here because
cuz basically is threatening Bishop g4
so I'm gonna play H to stop that and now
I think I'm gonna play with you one
maybe let's see so he doesn't have any
actual threats here so yeah I'm just
gonna play rook e1 and finish my
development so there should be six I
could take play something else too like
don't really see anything else so I'm
just gonna take and play just just try
to play this a little bit more slowly
but promise I I don't really have the
right squares for my pieces here so no
clear work t3 I'm probably worth d1 94
I've got work d7
I have six uh that was a slight error on
my part so I'm gonna have to probably
blitz again and this this might not be
so pretty yeah I just not not really not
ideal
so let's see okay so if I don't play eh
let's see what else I can do here to
kind of just chill out it's a little bit
hard to kind of just sit and wait in
this position unfortunately I'm okay
wait today stage 3 yeah that was just
terrible game I'm just gonna try and
play some other people don't feel like
playing Daniel right now so let's see
who else is on 5c 493 d5 okay so pretty
standard English takes takes d4 efore
maybe 97 also moves so in e4 so you want
to do it here hmm b6 to play Bishop g5
or Bishop b5 maybe
so if he takes on d4 I could take back
with the pawn or I can go Bishop c6 to
protect the pawn and attack his rook so
you lose rook f8 which is weird so I can
take the knight first of all and win a
pawn I could play Bishop c6 or Queen a
four or a lot of options here um I think
I'm just gonna take the pawn no maybe
I'll take with the con I guess I'll just
take with the pawn Bishop c5 Queen d5 I
guess or take and play like a four
the problem here is it's bishops of
opposite color so it's gonna be a little
bit hard to try and press him I think
maybe I'll just play Knight d4 looks
looks solid no weaknesses
there should be some enough three over
PA probably Bishop e3 although he does
have rook e8
maybe I can play Bishop g5 and kick the
rook or Bishop it may be visual g5 yeah
bishop or wait no takes takes takes and
it's d1 probably he'll take I would
assume or c5 Bishop e3 one or the other
but we'll see if six now I can play push
before probably and I really want to go
rook d7 if I can it's gonna be hard to
get that but
basically I want to play G for h4 at
some kind of f4 f5 at some point if I
can get it
although he just wondered a pawn here
maybe Brooksie it would see one and
something is gonna be falling here for
Bishop c4 okay so now I think I play a
four a five I could play a four here but
probably playing a four is then it
becomes a draw so I'm just gonna keep
playing trying to play for the win I
don't know why I'm trying to win this
exactly because it's borderline
impossible to win but okay okay so he's
trying to so we're both kind of trying
to like pretend that we're trying to win
here when we really are well maybe now I
can go f6 take six b4 or Bishop c3 to
play for six as well so okay so now he's
actually trying to win or not when I
don't really understand what's going on
here is that six I'll play e5 I'll
probably go keen e7 I assume now I could
take and play Bishop d2 could also play
b5 maybe what's this or Bishop d4 a lot
a lot of options again so let's play p5
probably cakes now I could play Shaq and
maybe g5 is a move or b6 is a move as
well I think b6 makes more sense here a
two-eyed Bishop d6 and a1 takes takes b7
I think I'm okay Oh yo yo I just missed
that Queen work takes be one and he's
got Queen c3 so I just completely
bungled it all right
that was pretty terrible that was just
terrible man all right let's say time to
slow it down a little bit
sure just been winning that game quite
easily I just got a little bit careless
at the end there five there should be
seven six bish eight three six probably
597 I want to play for c5 next move
almost regardless of what he does Knight
h3 play Queen b6 this pretty much has
turned into a French but he put upon an
each six which is either a good thing or
a really bad thing I'm not sure which so
a3 a5 you have to let's play Bishop e7
again probably standard f6 castles
something along these lines me two
castles Bishop g5 and I could take on d4
and if he takes I just take on e5 and
take E 5 annotations down pawn and
pretty much is lost
kingi 294 he wants to go clean up for
Queen f4 do I have any moves not really
so I'll just go back to D south and then
play we're key eight and now I'll start
to just just push push my pawns here
I'll play e5 nächsten everything starts
to open up
there should be three what does that do
if I just tank Queens you 528 if Bishop
g6 just HD six when people are tired
they start losing when people start
losing the hips had your desire to win
that they cannot think of anything else
and they keep losing and losing well I'm
afraid that's actually not the case
right now but but but thanks for the
thought it's a interesting thought so
you kiss resigns next game 56 F for
Queen e7 Knight f3 could be a problem
for him so I'll play g3 probably f6 or
maybe Knights and six something like
that it's a 97 just play Bishop g2
counsels probably castles I assume I'll
play Knight e4 or night C 3 bullets are
possible tango play Knight c3 Knight for
probably 96 maybe g6 is also moved
might be six of a play for maybe to play
a five so you place a five himself
I take write a five probably tags tags
so now I'm threatening to play Knight
takes d5 so as to kind of make those
mind what he's trying to do here
please Rocky eight which just hangs d5
though I think
so it takes I'll just go rookie 5 these
looks like a take on yet I don't really
want to but I don't really work out 5
yeah maybe we're cat 5 is just better
and if you please work d8 I can just
move my queen to like f1 please not any
force not Queen g4 maybe or I can just
play like Queen e2 if I take cakes and
play Queen f3 he goes rookie sobbing
rook F one looks pretty sensible
now someone says wait what sanaka shirt
the shirt I'm wearing right now is the
grand chest or shirt from last year so
it's just a pretty standard shirt
nothing nothing special six do I play E
for and go for the win or do I play
queen g4 or c4 maybe maybe c4 isn't
leave Ashley c4 yeah I like C Forks now
night before I'm gonna play like workout
six or something and just like this has
to be winning somehow so Queen d2 Bishop
f6 Queenie three work out - oh wait does
he know Queen e6 I take the rook Queen
if he goes Queen six I take and I've got
wrote that they ain't made so please
Queenie sit - no I just take and I like
I just pointed out I've got rook F ain't
made so he's gonna have to take official
and now I just play Ricky - and close to
victory have you plays aged six I'm just
gonna track and go broke up seven as
Knights out of play here as well which
doesn't doesn't help matters work out
seven to move you know five I think I'm
just gonna play simple try to force
exchange us here that's a pretty Queen
so it's just a gun pretty pretty
standard stuff probably h3 take see 697
I'm gonna castle this action is a lot
like a caro-kann actually I just froze
you out c5 for no reason so now I've got
d4 with the four cones Bishop on the
night
there should be five now if I take and
play e5 if I take on d4 takes and play
e5 takes 84 isn't this just again I feel
like this guy's blond around a little
bit now so e5 I guess he's not Bishop e3
d4 Bishop g5 f6 and he's probably losing
but I'm not sure maybe it's some tricks
here like Bishop d7 Queen d7 maybe he
can move his knight or Bishop g5 Essex
bish page 4 I guess tanks for McLean I
see 5 now he 4 is hanging on someone
just said tell me that's a dry white
white things has not Chardonnay I don't
know it could be either I'll let you
guys figure out which one it is
so anyway melancholic as weight is
hikaru pro-israel um I'm not really sure
what that what that is that a good thing
or bad thing I'm not really sure what
that's implying so I'm not really sure
what that's supposed to mean at any rate
it's a 96 and I want to hit his Bishop
but I'm also gonna hit this Bishop to it
now I'm just gonna play f5 about 4 and
try to really shut his bishop down here
I've also got e 4 coming as well which
is important so please after 3 is 2 e 4
is not a move now I mean F 4 still is
always there I don't really want to play
off or maybe I can just play but if I
play rook the 8th inning goes rook rook
e1 or work fe 1 and there could be
problems here too so I'm just gonna play
F for now I had a 5 and I really want to
put a night on e 3 if I can
so I'm putting a knight on you three I
think I'm just gonna sidestep a Chuck
with King h8 c 3 now he wants he really
wants this diagonal if he can get it so
I'm gonna play the Queen up 7 he'll
probably take Queen g6 takes I could
play with d4 here if I want to if I take
with a pawn which also seems reasonable
not sure what he's doing so he plays
rook c1 so he's trying to play on C foss
like a play h5 g for maybe a little bit
risky perhaps but I'm gonna go for it
because I really want to force him to
take him he doesn't take I'm going g4
and g3 or GI 3 and I'm just coming right
for the King and I just blunder yep I
just did blunder actually tactics 101
yeah that's just terrible so II five if
I play Knight b5 who's got d4 so I'm
gonna go night c2
d foreplay 95 if he takes I went his
queen and he has no Bishop before Chuck
he goes 28 5 we've got Bishop d2 so goes
Bishop e6 single play be for e3 I'll
just play eat four here
this beast 7 I could take the bishop I
could also not I mean I'm just gonna
take the bishop try to play with the two
bishops here hopefully Bishop d3 thank
you 7 I think I'm just gonna castle
castle so I could play p4 here I
complete b3 as well I can also play up
for or f3 both are possible I think I'm
just gonna play f3 so now Knight c5 I
can maybe go gosh me too or just b3 so
h6 gonna play which page for try to
force them to play g5 and now I'll just
retreat to g3 right before Knight takes
e4 FA for Queen before it could be a
problem so I e4 Knight before I really
want to play Knight before if I can make
it work I'm gonna it's probably gonna be
hard to make it work
so maybe 494 bish before Queen before
I'm still gonna go for it so III want to
see what he has
so hey I'll take six and our plane swing
this is actually way too standard for my
liking
but except to keep planning so we'll see
one night c5 or bish B 1 a 5 pretty dry
so I've got just moved ass that's
actually the biggest problem
I'm Way too slow way too slow for some
reason so
there's three ugly g49 s8 know I
complain I have to I'm just gonna play
before tried to build up my on my clean
side over here a little bit if I can
five eight four six eight four night be
to he'll probably play ninety-six and
just give me the pawn now since he he
blundered blundered night be to okay now
it plays Queenie six but if I take it
doesn't work so hopefully Bishop g3 but
now he blonde her this is what I was
waiting for his teeth and creatives with
a night on a fade he protected the Queen
so he could have just pushed c3
now if the knight on g6 he can't he
can't do the same thing and now if this
should be winning if I don't win this
game
I should really kill myself although the
time is close this game so there are no
guarantees
so I have faith now I'll just take I'll
probably take b5 + C 6 kg 7 lovely Queen
d5 here try to give them another chance
to take and give me more past pawns I've
also got a 5 B 6 coming but basically
here I think I just want to try and
exchange pieces because I am way down on
the clock or I was at least so it's kind
of important trying and I could take
takes is interesting actually I could
just take and play work - you won but I
don't want to take I want to try and do
something that isn't so so convoluted so
a6 now if I take take and play this a 5
or Bishop a5 right away
he's got work a7 rugby 1 okay no no
again I'm moving too slowly so I got to
be faster than this okay 7b 6 is just
good so probably hopefully work out 7
maybe like a 7 or P 1 or K 7 or work i7
c7 gait fatigue no it's no good so
probably work a 4 which broke I'll play
this this rook
five Jahna
way too slow
and there we go there we go finally
although he was very lucky to not lose
much earlier in the game so we should be
three um which line do I want to play
this game
oh I'll play p6 Queen d2 so he's trying
to play something like standard so I'm a
little bit confused just range search
all this take me five probably takes
takes 95 d5 or just d5 so probably takes
takes
Thanks
probably he'll just we're probably gonna
end up in an ending game so he cancels
so I can take takes and go like we know
six or PG five maybe why not
probably a four queen g2 we need five
King g8 or I can play King b1 but now
I've got rook c8 and now he's just
hanging the pond or g2 enough three
thank you just like 1 2 3 for the
donation so h4 it's gonna take we need 5
2 g8 and the problem of the positioner
is we put the rook on c8 before playing
with so now c2 is a weakness like you
can't go tonight our Forks then I'll
just take on c2h5 and he's trying to say
that he's oh he's got something here so
if I play rook e8 Queen f6 Queen e2 h g6
Queen c2 King a1 he's fine so I think
I'll play rook c8 so I'm putting off six
I can meet it with Ricky six
oh sorry it's just like 2 2 3 not 1 2 3
sorry so I'm trying to do like just
multitask at the same time as I play
sorry you guys if I got that sorry about
that
so Queen c7 I wish graph 3 HG HG maybe
or just rookie - HGH is also interesting
so we take so I can take with the Queen
I can also play Bishop takes f3 which is
very unusual probably it doesn't work
but fish about 3 worked you want meaning
h1 gf7 and queens t3 is mate so I can't
do that so I'm probably just gonna have
to take and I got to play work g1 worked
you to take stakes and we place them at
a game here or I can just ignore it and
play like fish about 3 but that doesn't
really make a lot of sense so I'm simply
- it takes now probably h5 isn't moving
don't know if h5 is good the problem is
my king is so much more open than within
White's King here so he takes and I'll
play probably work CA just hit the pawn
on c2 c1 queen g6 and I mean it's hard
because here my king is more open but I
also have past H bond as well so there
are Trump's but there are also problems
here as well so Queen D a teenage 7 b 4
else play with c4
Queen d2 probably just clean up five F 3
B 4 everything's a little bit loose here
Freud speed through workout for well g1
just take it for chief 5 I got rooked b3
so he goes King in two but now I've got
rook F 2 now I get C 2 as well so I was
a slight mistake so goes Queen D once
all just I could play Queen C 2 here
actually Queen c2 looks right because
he's got double pawns so surely this has
to be winning if I plays correctly just
cuz the doubled pawns like he can't
create anything here so I just want to
run this pawn right up the board now I'm
just gonna go age 3 and oh and I just
blundered wrote a ch3 oh shoot
unbelievable terrible oh but did he hang
b5 as well yeah I did but I missed this
much too late here I kind of just
wandered this completely that's not
gonna get it done so bad so bad
b5 cakes 95 castles
Bishop a5 Bishop d6 I'll play out for
try to open something on this a file f5
if Knight a5 probably Bishop b3 or maybe
maybe I'll 6 tonight at 5 just go back
of 693 basically trying to put the night
here so b6 clean up 3
he can't move the rooks on e7 hangs
it's a probably Bishop d7 and now I
could be night age five but I'm just
gonna play like if I played be for a
five takes takes doesn't feel quite
right so I'm gonna play c4 try to try to
keep everything relatively flowing here
in this position we need 794 tonight a
six free pod
I see keep movin xxs there are more
valuable things in life than online
chess rating steak and chips for example
do you just like Queen f7 you really
just give me a free Brooke that was
random I was reading the chat and I
didn't I didn't even see the completely
out sovereigns it's kind of funny
so this is just playing a Berlin just
want to see what exactly his his idea is
normally I don't play the Berlin when
I'm streaming for rather obvious reasons
but I feel like seeing what he wants to
do exactly 93 so he wants up a night of
five I guess please see five here night
of five ninety six ninety five King King
Fe it's an interesting position c3 is
hopefully Bishop a5 do you wanna clip
there should be five or I could play
maybe even she's sick I'm just gonna put
the fish pond and maybe Bishop a4 was
better to hit the rook I don't know for
sure than Bishop c6 but ninety three I
could play g6 I could play work d8 a lot
of options here but I'm gonna play
something here I'm gonna play b5
I only know if this makes much sense or
not but I'm just gonna try and do
something along this diagonal this is
actually very unusual this is a very
non-standard concept I don't think I've
ever seen this before where you play b5
C for Bishop d6 against the in this sort
of Berlin setup so this is this is
really unusual so I play Knight c5
ninety five ninety three maybe could
also play no h5 doesn't really make
sense g6 doesn't make sense either so
I've got h5 f da face glam I think I'm
gonna play rock d8
so he takes I'll take about five nights
e5 obviously job LDL gems LG dem so it's
hot new theory in the making yeah I mean
this I don't know how to calls taught in
the theory but I'm definitely trying
something something different now I want
to put a knight on d3 if I can hit b2
and b3 now 93 he has b3 so I'm gonna go
King c8 probably hold a 95 anyway I'm
gonna go 93 no problem let play 97 would
be my guest just to get rid of the
Bishop so takes takes probably takes
takes but my knight on d3 is much better
than relative to his night on g3 so an
e5 b2 are hanging and I've got Knight f2
with the fork so he's probably losing a
pawn here which is good news c6 free
free rook floor muchas gracias let's see
what the next next game or is he is he
done
and I guess he's done he doesn't want to
play more how very disappointing um okay
I'll play some some other people plays
rafa nadal i guess alright play d5 not
d6 I'm expecting just standard Kings
Indians now it's gonna be something kind
of weird I don't know what this is gonna
turn into
so b5 Bishop d3 I guess we thought oh
but II God though yeah that's that's
that's another phrase that one could say
I guess you could if you wanted to a6
I'm gonna play e5 and I'm gonna try to
put a knight on e4 and maybe take
advantage of c5 take advantage of these
weak pawns by can 94 but should be one
fish about five play a 395 I'm gonna
play rook e1 I don't know why I mean
night h4 tree for both possible just
rook e1 Phil's naturally correct 97 so
you really wanted he's gonna play for c5
there's no doubt about that now only
question is can I somehow do something
to prevent that so maybe Bishop d2 to
move or g4 don't really like either of
those options maybe h4 is no that makes
no sense me so I'm gonna go for it so he
takes I take probably e6 night a 3 of c5
I think I can just take on d5 and play
like e6000 first so takes now b4 is the
move I really I really think I'm just
gonna go b4 and try to play this
structure I don't really know what's
happening this structure after c4 but it
feels like I should be slightly faster
so I'm gonna play Bishop d2 to stop a5
first and I move on ith to f4 g4 alright
f e8 as expected now I could play Knight
g4 right away perhaps or f4 but I think
I'll just play Bishop c3 stop any c3 is
and I'll play Queen f3 put pressure here
and then I'll go 92 for next when I to
523 of 94 f3 tags tags
okay 96 but 96 doesn't actually create
any sprout so I'm gonna go clean up tune
if he goes night if I'm just gonna hit
him with g4 because he's actually
helping me continue to build up my
position that's kind of the problem with
all these ways to Tempe so he plays off
five which is what I expected
now I could play eight four but I think
actually here I'm just gonna plate night
f1 or gaeaf I don't really want to play
g5 so I'm gonna play what do I want to
do here let's see so I've got a four is
the possibility queen up three also as
possible which i think is what I'm yeah
Queen f3 and just play for like night of
193 makes them those Suns and if you
please look at it I can play g5 if I
really want to or I can take now I
actually can take because I was gonna
take with the pawn I'm King age to a 4
if Knight G 60 hangs the pawn on d5 it's
starting to look good so Rick g8 player
q1 do I have any of any other moves and
they gonna play work f1 protect the pawn
here on a4 also but to open this
diagonal as well like if I get this P 1
P 1 H 406 its gg
so let's see what he wants to do Queen
c6 now Bishop cheat fish eat one and I'm
not sure he kind of has to cope with
something instantly now or else it's
just game over so he takes I'll kovash
page for now this is gonna get really
ugly in a hurry I suspect so make she's
fixed on Knight f5 is a move Bishop a4
no it's all Chuck Bishop g7 I was
expected now I can take on d5 lot of
options here I think I'm just gonna play
Queen takes he has to take the Queen I
take and he just resides okay
so I'll play a Carl Kahn this game I'll
play Knight f6 try play something a
little bit more imbalanced I see
someone's saying now there's some
discussion the chat about Roger and Rafa
tough discussion I mean I'm a huge huge
Rafa fan so what can I say thank you
logs logo at the GG for the donation as
I was saying I'm a huge huge Rafa fan so
I'm gonna disagree with some of the
people in chat I mean I think I mean I I
really do like Rafa I mean I like the
style that he plays I think clearly it's
much more he's much more into it than
Roger certainly I mean you can you can
feel the passion the intensity all the
time with Rafa where it's rock with
Roger I mean I never really got that
sense about the passion and just like
the the struggle of it all I've never
really sensed that with Roger so I mean
I'm I'm a huge Rafa fan and he's he's
always gonna be my my favorite of course
I will say since some people are
mentioning Novak I mean I'm a big fan of
Novak - but the problem Novak isn't like
he's always injured if Novak was like
never injured if he could play the
lovely played in 2011 I mean the guy is
just a beast but the problem is Novak
hasn't really played at that level in
quite some time he always just seems
injured unfortunately
it's a B 3 now the problem here is I've
got some issues with my queen side so
I'm gonna try and play a 5 maybe Bishop
v4 is an idea here maybe I just want to
play b6 and c5 later not quite sure yet
as for Novak yeah I mean I think there
are many problems Novak I mean first of
all he's always injured but I feel like
the moment he started believing in all
the food ooh the you know trying to be
super health-conscious is when
everything started to go downhill so I
think probably that was a big mistake on
his part I mean anytime you start buying
it to voodoo or anything of that sort I
think it's always a bad sign so I have
to say that like you know I'm I think
that's when things started to kind of
like go wrong for him certainly before I
was a rookie ate again I want to open up
the diagonal for the bishop so age for
now I kind of have to play Bishop before
just to simplify because h5 is a big
problem otherwise
so I see Boyd Owen says I don't like the
noises were off of me while sitting
whilst hitting the ball I thought it was
really funny actually that like when
Novak was playing against Chun I think
it wasn't the Australian Open in the
third round second round whichever round
it was when he had a when he lost that
like in the second set tiebreak when it
was down to this this moment were like
he where I think he had on what was it
it was like break point against I think
it was like five four four three at some
point in the middle of point it went a
little and then he hit - no - like that
finally he misses a cross-court I
thought it was really funny actually to
see that happen where he just starts
like making these crazy noises in the
middle of a point out of nowhere and
that actually mind me a lot of Sharapova
maybe I can find that point but there's
there's some point in the middle where
he hits like he hits to inside and out
four hands just right hitting it
cross-court to inside outs and he just
make these like huge grunting noise and
then he like nuts the third shot and I
thought that was pretty pretty funny to
see excited I don't really feel like
Novak does that on critical points in
the middle of a point in the middle of a
point but he uh he totally did that and
that matched in the Australian okay I
saw those absolutely hilarious
93 I'll take this is a very weird
position actually it's kind of like some
kind of weird position I'm not really
sure what's going on so I'm gonna take
he'll take with the Queen Castle maybe
Queens c4 not really sure what his next
move is here in fact so we'll see
so castles so I mean I'm gonna sack up
on here try and open up this and also
more importantly open the diagonal as
well
Queen d5 I'll just take the free pawn
you take it - what is giveth
I mean what's what's the saying I feel
like there's a saying similar in what's
it altered carbon since I watched the
show recently there's something like
like with free pause I feel like it's
the saying in that show where you say we
are envoys we take what is offered and I
feel like he he offered me the free pawn
I gotta take it like there's there's not
much much more to it so Ricky eight
playoff six try and open it up or
teenage 592 I don't have any tricks
doesn't look like or wait do I have some
brilliant tricks I don't know if it
works but I had the concept is so great
you guys that I have to go for it I
don't know if this is gonna work but I
have to go for this this trick he's if
he plays 92 I had 96 now again I don't
know if it works
96 here takes Queen g4 and it doesn't
quite work does it
Queens you for e5 it doesn't quite work
that's so disappointing
now let's play queen g4 try to create
it's right along this diagonal instead
I mean basically I wanted him to play on
I takes D to and I had this brilliant 96
trick which may or may not have worked
but I had to go for for you guys does I
mean you guys are the fans and if I
don't go for the brilliant beautiful
tricks even if they don't work then
really what's the point
I mean what's the point of playing g6
think I'll just take and I get my
brilliancy anyway somebody oh I'm gonna
get a brilliancy anyway you guys this is
so awesome
he's gonna take my queen i'ma take it I
go King f8 and boom 96 and I had Bishop
g7 with me
oh oh so brilliant Oh awesome
oh you guys get to see a brilliant
masterpiece this is what I wanted with
the other line but you didn't you didn't
play 90 XD too so it's it's gonna turn
this the same concept but from a
different order so uh takes Bishop g7
takes I make the Queen King g6 and
there's gotta be a major if there's not
a maid here that would be so upsetting
so let's see so if I play rook g7 he's
gonna go
teenage sex maybe let's see okay I've
got time so by Chuck King age five I
don't know
okay I'm not throwing a check on f7
first maybe that was wrong so nice got
King G five and maybe I messed this all
up H four no but I've got h4 h4 takes
Queen h7 in checkmate or wait no but if
I take and I take he's got Queen Queen
h5 I actually must have slept pretty
terribly so I thought it takes me as
queen h5 it's a rook e8
there has to be something here for sure
let's see but I'm way down on the clock
so I've also got to just start moving so
if I take it doesn't work replace them
in weird maybe rook c4
cakes and I completely mess this up
completely mess us up
but I still have a hope I'm way down on
time so I'm gonna actually like start
zoning and ID again you guys just to try
and see if I can't swindle him somehow
yikes I've got certainly fast and I just
wandered Knight g3 like an idiot hmm
that was so bad first of all I just
realized it in this position after h5 I
had this rotate to e for ideas rookie
400 g3 made that's the first thing that
I just realized and secondly I just
realized it in this position after let
me say so it takes king g6 just work g7
King h6 and I feel like there there had
to be a major but anyway there was
definitely me and I completely messed it
up for no no no good reason but yeah
that's very disappointing especially
missing rookie 4 because rookie forwards
was so obvious but a little bit too slow
and in the critical moments
so let's see who else is on line for
blitz let's see there's anyone else
online that was really really ridiculous
okay so I'm a collab or like okay let's
see 45 probably age six fish my fate I
have three all day 96
I've already put myself in a bad spot on
this game but he didn't he didn't
capitalize pay for I'll play Bishop g4
we need three castles i complete b5
night before play night before right
away
the question is how to take advantage of
plea bus sex try to put pressure
on b4 but should be 397 d1 take i could
also play knight c6 95 and make Bishop
e6 makes sense so it takes all take with
a knight put pressure on d4 now so he
goes III now I'm gonna play come
play Knight a5 here I can also just play
like B 585 I think I'm gonna play Knight
a5 though just to take away any tricks
f3 c5 again same kind of concept with d4
forking the bishop in the knight on c3
so we'll see I mean he kind of passed
the tape if he doesn't cake then he's
got big problem so take I'll take takes
before obviously 94 I'll just take the
bishop so he thinks I can play this beat
7 and also play Bishop b4 or it can play
something weird like bish beige shade
but I think actually Queen d4 looks
pretty logical because I hit B to I
threatened to exchange Queens and you go
c3 I just take the Queen Lautrec anyway
more importantly so this looks pretty
good
okay takes I'll take rook d1 r --c f d8
please be for now i could play a five
but i think I'm gonna play a 5c 3-shot
like it I think old don't want exchange
Brookes the i Dukes take time just take
h6 baby's got work a 1 now but okay
that's not gonna happen
48 the five ish before and I mean
basically the two bishops should should
rule the day essentially
g5 these five I'll just play like King
g7 King before so he's trying to do
something way over here
Thank You major oddball for the donation
now I guess I could just take I mean it
really looks really bit suspect but I
think I'm just gonna take and play king
of King off sexes on c6 I just take King
a5
I can play King e7 so he had smoother
Brooke before you can play c6 and now I
just Chuck and her okay to taketake c6
Bishop d5 king c5 I don't believe this
somehow he's hanging on that's a very
very unfortunate so I'll play rook da to
try and force an exchange of the rooks
and if he moves the rook off like rook
CT now I can throw in a shock and I
think Roxy for should work now yeah
because takes takes c6 Bishop d5 and I'm
just winning and it's important to know
what the King on b4 E is king c5 King e6
e7 but here with the King on a3 he's too
late and if I take let's see so I have
h3 I also I just have kinky sex simple
King d6 and now I'm threatening to just
take so he's gonna have to go c7 and
I'll King Gustav and I can just take and
now takes h3 is game over
so a pretty normal gun standard theory
efore properly or d63 probably castles
or Bishop a6 interesting you move queen
g4 and I'm basically trying to say that
he's flossing here that he doesn't have
enough but I don't know I mean he's
playing this really fast and he might
actually know what he's doing I don't
really understand what he's doing but
we'll see it's about ninety four ninety
two
okay I'll take Shh fourth plate g3 I
could also just play King me too and
finish development instead G through is
always there but I didn't really like it
so he goes Queen chief five so he's
trying to like trying to attack 94 Queen
g2 g3 Queen h5 g three queen h5 keaney
one looks okay
Queen e1 Queen f3 I don't see it so I'm
gonna go for it skinny one Queen f3 work
f1 work g3 Queen h4 it's just winning so
I can't I can't I can't tell your name
it's I think it's keep moving ex act
says um oh no did I just blunder no no
I'm still winning okay but keep moving
ex ex ex says I see Hikari please be
through it's quite but he doesn't play
b6 and the reason is cuz b6 is just bad
jauntily I have played b6 before impact
on some streams I've done it so it
wouldn't be the first time but um
generally it's not not idea so that's
that's why I don't do it Queen g6
noticed 94 and he has no d5 to the 10 so
it should just be over
I expect to resign here but I'll play p6
this time I'll give you guys what you
want n c3 Bishop b4
vish 83 now that's a weird I wasn't
expecting that so when I go Queen in
five-inch five
the Sri to Bush basics probably he'll
exchange but maybe not go c4
it's a slight problem hmm should be
seven just to go back play defensive 95
wait yeah that's kind of ugly oh maybe
I'll catch for just see tix 24:53 if I
play Knight h5 he's got black this is
ugly ugly ugly ugly p1 maybe Queen c2 or
yeah why not
if 97 King d7 of Queen g7 I count so
long but now he blundered Queen g7 now
I've got Queen g6 and I'm completely
fine maybe not completely but close to
completely now it takes HGD five takes
Bishop c3 is a problem so I'm gonna take
with us pawn here and takes and Bishop
c3 I've got work f8 so rookie 7 can see
8 3 work I feel and I don't know if I'm
okay here but I'm I'm fighting at least
maybe rookie something I had King d8
maybe I was better than what I did but
at any rate we'll see so I'm gonna go
King b7 he'll take rook see 146 were
caged 7 ft 6 and now we're gonna be pawn
and I'm not sure if I'm gonna actually
slower than than white here so I'm
pretty fast aged 62 in fact here I'm not
sure if I'm I'm slower at all maybe I'm
not in fact maybe I'm not even slower at
all rook d1 he's gonna have to take he's
gonna have to clean I mean maybe I'm not
maybe I'm just faster in fact maybe I'm
just winning
I could take out taurage so I'm gonna
take a tube sigh I mean I need my to
connected so g4b three maybe or a five
or I can just take actually I can just
take this truth is to putting maybe
we're a couple almost better first but
this still has to be winning somehow
broke up six work a seven King King a
six can be six I guess b7g 7 or 3 6 and
D 2 because work age six I can just
promote a queen I think yeah I should
just do one
with has to be winning but okay plays
ricochet fighting is taking over p7 bets
just came warmer yeah so I won with p6 I
don't know if I'll do it again
ah ridiculous it's not even the first
time this has happened
which is what's so sick about it
yeah disgusting
although no this is still completely
lost but I don't know maybe he'll maybe
he'll do something stupid here now it's
not like I mean he's gonna have to take
I mean I don't I don't know I mean how
almost is this in fact this is still
losing obviously but it's just
completely lost or not that's what I'm
not sure of mage six rook b1 try to play
for rook b8 if I can get it
c6 to prevent that okay I'll just play
Bishop oh did I just wonder play no 600k
but he didn't do that he plays that for
so he gives me a second shot so he wants
play III rafter I don't know which one
it's not clear if d2 maybe ninety fours
you know ninety four is no good so
rookie one is possible rook d2 is also
possible overworked utility e3 that's
not good and yeah that's that's just
going to lose the game
I mean he gave me a fake chance for for
no particular reason but
but this is are there five oh that's
enough with him
find someone else close his Smirnoff
online or okay I'll play slowly inside
Bishop c4 mm-hmm Knight f6 d3 so clearly
he just wants to play something slow and
quiet so h3 I'll take the e6 or 95 let's
play something something simple he sucks
Bishop e7 castles 92 slim play d5 now
wish me to just castles at night a four
night before so c3 non-slick Queen d7
off d8
all right a for a plate D for D for
looks pretty pretty normal
thanks I'll take 95 55 should be equal
do you wanna know what I take I don't
necessarily want to play like this but
I'm gonna try to do this just because
now is these wheat ponds that are not so
I'm not so well placed five per case for
probably cheese six of 4p to just be
five maybe maybe not be 5 or just be 5
why not why not just go for it so Ricky
won Queen b6 takes takes
I don't know why that he's not going to
take on e5
so I'm still following a chat you guys
it's just um trying to play at the same
time it's not not so easy I got some of
these stronger players and especially in
a fast time control
so please cheats arena I complete beat
four maybe why not
d4 now I could take him no Bishop d4
he's got rookie 695 rookie fly that's no
good so I take he'll take on beat 4
obviously maybe f4 f4 is interesting a
4G for a 4G for us but really what I
want to do but nice open b5 which is a
problem so if I click Queen b8 he's got
b5 anyway okay so I've also got to move
slightly quicker she's up for g4 Queen
six taste aches work at 8 no it's got to
be terrible now fortunate for Queen v8
or queen bee it right away yeah let's
let's see what he's got Queen B it's a B
5 I can take or play I don't know b5 d3
I guess now what am i doing b5 takes a
success takes very loud night of four I
there no night afore I just taken he
doesn't have night you since what am I
thinking losing my mind you've been to
hitting the rook and the bishop
I mean maybe he's gonna play workout 5k
stakes and
Queen g5 workup date night off I think I
can just take the take the bishop and
see someone donated sorry if I missed it
think he doesn't fire for subscribing
it's a sub and now I just promote to a
second no that's just GG i could take
either way I'll take with the eponymous
game
[Music]
faith reason moved here Berlin I'd
be four right so uh sorry someone else
subscribed you're doing this thing maybe
I missed something
it's 97 council tonight of 500 simply
chiii protect protect these pawns here a
rookie one finish development
Bishop f6 now complain 85 I'm gonna play
eight four try and play like b4 c4 just
really open it up if I can
like night chief I've tried to create
some threats along against these uh
these these kingside pawns play Knight I
could play like Bishop b4 Bishop c4 many
options now I'm gonna go Bishop c4 try
to open it up a little bit more d 894
try to kick this bishop
there should be seven I'm gonna play
Queen b3 protect the bishop put the
Queen here maybe it's better now for
like opening up this B file something
along those lines at least so we could
see one oh wow he's sax okay so he's
going all in okay this is interesting so
now I can take I could all just take e6
maybe and try to counter counter-attack
I think I'm gonna go for it
so I mean I don't know if this is good
but it makes at least it makes some
sense maybe maybe it makes no sense at
all but still still a try oh so he just
ignores he just please 94 just ignores
it completely okay so I have to take
obviously or do I have to take probably
I do have to take and just complain I
III retreat tonight if he takes I still
have rookie sticks in rookie one and
it's this is not quite trivial and ig5
was maybe better maybe maybe slightly so
he goes rookie - so he's trying - okay
so by plane tonight he's four he's gonna
go rook d4 back and he's gonna try to
say like what do you have here I play
rook see four kings takes Bishop takes
h4 Knight f6 proxy for looks good
doesn't look like it blunders anything
so why not
so okay work d8 so if I take maybe bc6
takes takes and I've got some other
movers maybe I just take and play like
work age three I'm gonna it's gonna take
him just clip this bh3 and try to just
like play normal cha settees gonna play
Bishop age for Bishop g2 and just play
like normal kind of move or no their
speech for I'm gonna have to take first
ago Bishop g2 he takes wait what
rookie fourth or stuff to King f1 GG we
have to King H to GG give you good looks
like GG easy everywhere here taking f1
what am I missing here clean out 16 f3
Queenie to Ricky to clean up 6.3 Queen
d2
rookie - yeah there's almost no way that
you can survive this
it's got pawns that are like misplace
everywhere
so alright so next game let's see what
he does here
okay call th3 what to do what to do I
play work yet I could also feel like g5
caveman
let's go caveman style try to attack him
ladies to caveman just all in just
attack attack attack clean eh 5.06 a
plane had a fornum is gonna play g4 just
keep on attacking try to open open more
more squares like if I can get the
bishop on a5 of garlic much more
diagonal and scope also try to attack
him so probably 90 g3 I would have soon
dish before is 0.06 is move go clean up
sex here Queen c2 hanging d4 though
rookie southern Bishop g7 night h5 work
f7 so just goes roof do you won you know
six actually now h5 a lot of bitched
about five one of my thinking so Brooke
do you sue Ricky something was not a
problem a rookie 7 Bishop e7 i thi
Bishop a5 that's not a problem
perky to know maybe Bishop e6 hit the
rook e1 this poet rook e8 basically try
to just harmonize all my pieces here
because the bishops are fairly deeds
that they're not not ideal yet but
they're decent when a force he wants 90
XD 5 so I've got rook f8 here and I
don't know if it works or not but he
basically wants Knight takes d5 and I go
Bishop c4 95 is no good if I go Bishop
c4 Queen e7 is still up to their work a
fake mean it looks tasty h2 fish before
92 their work up sex queen see a king g7
yeah that does not work Bishop c4 b3
Queen c3 maybe let's see efficiency
force a move here
and so I see a Starcraft gecko says can
you throw back to your old days and play
the play the play the Halloween gambit
um we'll see maybe it's it's always a
possibility this would be a real take if
he takes I've got rookie one so he does
take okay so what's his concept he just
wants to play it's the rookie wanting
once wants to take and play like teenage
two or something he goes can issue right
away okay so but he's basically saying
when I take the rook he's got some kind
of Perpetual maybe does he really look
perpetual here that's really hard to
believe but it's possible I guess but if
I don't take the rook I have nothing
better really so I mean I kind of have
two unjust just see what he has
although it probably does this have a
perpetual here because I didn't realize
it Queenie sucks with the idea of Queen
eh I can wait but I've got Queen she's
seven maybe it's not so clear actually
because now it's running
checkmate on on h4 as well
g3 okay so he's trying to create some
threats so I played Queen e5 Knight h6
is a very big threat I guess so
he's starting thats me rookie six and I
block now he's just Boston he's got
nothing Queen g5 work ethic
okay another one another one in the can
let's see 97 I guess is the move 98 to
move also place C 3 and C 2 and play
play Jocasta Gus Thank You 7i k h4 it
could also play E 4 but I'm gonna play
Age 4 4 8 5 now I'm gonna play E 4 let's
see what eise can i play for so 95 e 5
tonight at 5 we've got B 4 or bhishm a 3
but I think B 4 makes more sense just to
kick the night away could Castle I can
also play Bishop d3 I think Casas makes
more sense on Bishop h6 I'm Knight g5 so
here it was Queen e7 like Queen b3 maybe
just to provide something a5 stuff
da King V 196 playing c4 by Fiat I've
got c5 I guess or a 3 thanks I'll take a
bishop obviously so I don't hang aged
for push-ups e2
so he does play c5 snow I could take and
play Knight g5 maybe or I could play
something else I mean maybe Knight g5
doesn't really make sense b5 94-94
there's a slight problem so let's see
it's the Bishop f5 e f5 is what you want
to do play b5 94 94 CD for work you want
Queen h4 is not really what I want
maybe Teague's in 85
don't know if this is actually any good
but it's worth a shot
I mean these sevens now I've got east
six if I wanted to really try and open
it up so e six takes in rookie one maybe
yeah it takes in rookie one looks pretty
strong actually
if he doesn't do that he goes like work
he ate then I've got roof t1 myself so
it's not not trivial
so he's trying to think and figure it
out so you please see before but I think
now I can immediately see five a before
I mean this looks this looks very very
dangerous see five takes 96 and what's
his fault Queen d3 is trading play
Knight c5
I mean Queen defaut whoa whoa whoa what
is this
make c6 what is this what is he playing
for here exact I'm a little bit confused
Queen d3 so I take he takes my cake oh
he's got rook 83 at the end oh no always
God takes takes rook a3 oh I completely
missed that
Oh probably I probably can just flag in
here oh maybe I just wanna board say so
we're gonna play something pretty
standard again I fish of d4 maybe maybe
not oh wait he's he's really bugging me
to flip which takes d4 so I take he
takes bishop state sorry Beast III that
looks suspect so I'm gonna I'm gonna
trust him here knock her out the pond g5
okay so now the h-60 takes
95 Queen d8 if night night of 496 C 3 e
maybe three so I could take with the
Queen may between d4 or bishop d4 bishop
before actually looks much more natural
so I'll take I'll take I'll play 97 d1
I've worked b8 I've got a knight c5 also
both are possible 95 actual looks more
practical now if I take he's got bishop
cheese sex so I can't just take I played
Queen a5 maybe then c3 maybe Queen c7 or
queen of six or something along
everything I'll just play something else
six
if you take sigh takes c3 work b8 and
what I'm probably okay
okay so he plays b3 so click Bishop c3
probably we're key to or work f1 f1 okay
I'll click split a5 solidify my knight
in my bishop here so he plays a four
player d8 should be five like a play
Bishop d4 or bishop deep no I'm actually
neither of those moves make my son so
I'm just gonna play King G solving hey
why did I just exchange for no good
reason
Fischer d4 Stokes before I've got 94
oh no he's got a 60 on oh yeah yeah II
thought I could just play Knight e3 but
then he's got he's got a six
although maybe here not all hope is lost
so there might be some drawing chances -
III play like this pace 7
you know probably just lost
unfortunately but 595 g5 maybe some some
weird drawing hopes if I can get us
sexing if I can get up 6 maybe there's
some drawing chances so there's c4 which
I suspect this a bad move actually so
play of 697 might be 3 in fact actually
King see through I've got night c5
forcing an exchange of the Knights and
that has to be a draw so close a5 trying
it so I take you go c5 but I think I can
just play Knight c5 gonna make a draw so
g4 I could play f5 I could also just
play King d6 I guess this should just be
a draw unless I'm missing something but
but I could take issues on eh for so I'm
just gonna keep on waiting here
okay so let's see so he's trying to do
something or I don't know what exactly
that was pretty terrible but when is a
win okay so once place Bishop g4 I guess
I guess this is a concept for the day
so all right playoff for d3
but h4 just to see what he wants to do
just play h5 no matter what okay that's
good to know it's Knight g5 c follows to
the bush be to keep it slow keep it
simple this should eat d4 interesting
okay I'll play e4 Queen a5 a complete
Queen d2 I guess
it's naive 7 or qu one takes tape with
the aplomb but I'm gonna take with the H
pawn here
well I probably would have done better
to keep this rook here and have taken
with the a truck but nonetheless play e5
try to open up another diagonal for my
bishop okay see it I could play b4 I
could put a 4 B 4 is the move that I
want to play maybe just c3 just trying
to open up more more diagonals for my
bishops c4 Wow okay if I take or play
visually for what's he doing this abuse
rough day Keeney to our kini to is not
kini to Bishop e3 work c2 takes takes
bit shaky teen youtubers faith roots see
three takes riff d3 working Brooksie too
so
- Buffy okay I could play b4 I guess b4
cd3 or what else
knocking just let's say Keaney three
buffet three works eat - maybe King III
doesn't look right though so let's see
so rook c2
we should see five I could play kini - I
guess get out of the way
especially d4 so is this not a freak
pawn if I came I guess he's got well
rook c5 I taking player D to miss Bishop
c5 so basically blundered upon play
Bishop d3 protect the pawn if he goes
work before I've got Bishop d2 and rook
d8 I've got work h3 tuck the bishops d7
okay so now I've got three
put everything back on squares I won't
want it to be on oh my go - b3
seven so you're still making a tough
girl like I really don't know what I'm
trying to do it it's very hard to play
as please see three someone I'm gonna
try it something work be to maybe roof
be five go straight five no no I'm
starting to unwind a little bit so maybe
I can create something here
Oh gage 3c six really don't want to take
that clear would be one too slow if I
play this before it doesn't work but I'm
also way down so finally I'm just gonna
like oh just wonder okay
okay so Oh actually the screen so same
for you guys yeah it's still still good
okay
actually is this kind of similar to what
I had against a t-bone earlier in the
protest like something very similar to
this in fact although he played with the
pawn that for whereas I'm playing with
the pawn he is the pawn enough to here
Oh
b3 while I'd c5 right away it's 92 take
of 94 95 and c5 next move all right
after three I could take I could play
queen 85 but I'll just take and get the
Queen off of the e2 square hitting the
pawn and I'll go clean a5 to see a for
c4
took before I've got c3 where c1 all
this take and play clean c2 I stopped
Bishop g5 though which I kind of
overlooked but it goes Queen do you want
take I'm just gonna play rook c8 here
it's still very balanced position not
much happening maybe slightly better for
black maybe very slightly
it's alright let's see so he plays b4
and I could take I guess and play like
Bishop c3 me promise is probably gonna
turn to some some like some long end
game where it's like I'm up a pod but
I've nothing special
Bishop c3 or though he has roots you
know rook c1 Rick soon he takes a sort
of c4 yeah that's gonna turn to
something very annoying something like
takes rook c4 probably probably I mean
I'm gonna end up with an extra pawn and
some like long end game five against
four which is a draw maybe I could
squeeze him here takes rook c2 3 a 5
here a 5 b7 work before so it a 5
actually makes sense
rook b5 I can just take the point is by
playing a5 I support a roof before idea
at some point later on later on
those were p5 so let's take the pond not
getting greedy but I need to take an
hour before or efore know probably this
work v4 makes no sense this is gonna
take on a five rope takes e4 be I mean
probably I have to take on b6 I can't I
just can't get away with that
Chuck put the rook on b7 three play like
h5 say three input each four I gots
maybe here is this this pawn structure
is not quite what he wants so I might be
able to close for a little bit more than
mr. draw to g3 interesting so I'm clear
cut rook b3 soften it up play up five
basically I want to try and yell I want
to get a position where I've three
connected where I've three connected
pawns if I can't
now I please King F for it but I had a
five then King g5 so I don't play King
l6 with the idea of playing e5 if if I
can get he's gonna have to take on that
five now wait Roxy six can I just go g5
enough c4 and he's just lost
and play the same kind of positioning
I'm probably d44 queen 85 Queen d2 and
play something very similar to what we
just have the last game 97 maybe e5 I
mean I'm just gonna play this very very
much the way that I played the last game
and see what happens all the differences
curious I have the rook on a 1 and EH
when the rook on a 1 is much better
placed in the previous game fish about
three probably ninety seven or something
King f8 okay eight for me and I'm gonna
play a five bet I could play a six here
but I think I'm gonna play c3 instead so
Brooksie sub not good again I could play
a six but I don't think I want to play a
six here because I think I think I want
this pawn to be a week later on so this
B for B seven I'm gonna play King III
when I give 94 so maybe that wasn't so
perfect or a six maybe or teeth for a
lot of possibilities now a six is a move
that I cannot like here so I'm going to
go for it so I'm p6 I can play d4 maybe
okay plate teeth before he goes 96 so I
can't play d4 quite yet but I could play
Bishop d7 to plant the bish bumpy's
summon and protect the pond and I feel
like this would be to maybe night before
d4 doesn't make sense but like work a
494 I'm like not quite right somehow
hopefully work b1 try to re really sort
my pieces a little bit here so he goes
rook d7 so he wants to play like
cliquish before just protect the pawn
don't don't do anything crazy thing f8
no here I I don't have beef or so so I'm
gonna play work 8 - I really want to go
b4 if I get the chance it plays Knight
a5 I could take taking it's actually
kind of interesting I think I'm gonna
take play work to you to see see he's
put his King on the wrong square kind of
I played be for takes I'll take c8 now I
play work c4 here maybe
no works before sorry he's gotta pass th
pawn and what am I thinking
gotta do something drastic so I'm play
with d4 takes takes
like rookie - I kind of Miss played this
a little bit so I gave him the King
position of shunt AB can be five bit now
I have work a forum about root D 47 or
56 workout six commune 650 for
seven unclear of t6 now d4 if the h4
I've got King out 3 H 3 km g3 oh wow oh
wow do I miss that ohyeah ohyeah wait
wait-wait-wait-wait-wait
yeah that's not gonna get done you guys
I'll be back in few minutes
all right you guys back back to work
let's see it's the next game okay did
you say taking a short break I'm no I'm
not taking anything tonight a3 Bishop b4
should be 39 f6 we need to d5 sorry you
guys a new hat what no doubt or Lauren
Scott earlier man
we should be 297 takes 27 three the
rotation see
- I'm gonna play c5 try to open it up a
little bit more
Bishop d3 place c4 I don't really love
c4 but it's a move 95 Bishop d2 b5 as
possible I mean maybe I'm just going to
go King it's out there just solidify g4
now I still want to go b5 but I don't
know to make sense now Bishop c6h4 I
don't really I don't see the expansion
coming here but hopefully it looks just
to be safe try age 6.4 at Knight f6 but
I don't want to go f6 design he'll go up
for g5 right now I just want to keep
this efore Square open so takes play
Knight d5 it's one option I think
actually the best is a far I've got B
for maybe so he doesn't go he goes a4
anyways shuttle with no fear no fear at
all but I'm just I'm gonna Chuck a pawn
here and see what what's happening
little p8 if b5 just take and take and
take and I don't know maybe maybe I
maybe it's just a draw which would be
really kind of annoying but um let's see
if I can work some magic here so please
be 5 so let's see if I play I don't know
like rook b6 maybe everything he just
takes if I take take and play work b5
I'm gonna just draw probably I guess but
you know what whatever let's let's let's
go for it let's let's let's see what
he's got here I go King d6 takes takes 4
P 7
I'm gonna go for it so if he takes 4
takes g5 work h2
so he does he just goes for no fear
takes
you should see one logical move please
see - I could also clear h1 mr. Burke h1
oh now I gave him a five why did I give
him a five so it takes his work these
six they're just getting my free move
that I should have thrown a shocking
like night a 4 C 3 or C - sorry
seven
but II saw then I can take can't I I
hate flagging the guy but I'm gonna have
to flag him again
alright let's say so b5 New York c3 the
move rookie for to move up it works III
night before I'm probably I'm just gonna
go all and just just just stack the
house see what he's got
so I'm going to take on this ugly
about five which I think I'm gonna do
our employees so I'm just gonna sack
just to see takes I'm gonna play if I
play e6
so it takes I can take out seven now if
I want to I think I'm just gonna take on
c3 and c7 coming out five now so
obviously it's completely busted for me
but maybe I can suck out somehow maybe
so now when you take the East six now in
kc6 I'm gonna have clean g5 hitting the
king and his rug so queen c3 Queen g5 is
always a move east seven is not of me so
whatever pink okay so at least I've got
a draw here but I can play work h1 and
he can't cut I don't think he can cut me
off he can't cover both G 2 and G 1 so
he's just getting truck mated here which
is awesome
please d6 of King G ones and move east
seven is also moved I think he something
makes more sense
although Kim Jiwan is probably good
enough maybe maybe not
so okay so now I have to go Kim Jiwan
and yes eight remote I take and I get
Queen Queen d7 and I'm picking off the
pawn on T 2 for B for Knight d5 c5 fact
I actually think I played this exact
line against on the other day
we need you to snow and cake or I can
play h6 I think I'll sleep I'm not like
age six here
[Applause]
let's say so he's got fish before
obviously now I think I'm just gonna
play Knight f6 just play standard
standard positional moves again Bishop
d6
about something let's see so I can't
take on d5 obviously play push my feet
maybe push my feet take stakes
I don't really know what I'm doing this
game I've kind of again put myself in a
messy messy messy spot but wait can I
take now or I can take these six and
play Queen c7 obviously I can take d5
look like a bishop no than 85 if I play
Knight d5 just fish buff ain't i b6 is
no good so probably I just need to be
solid
so let's let's see what's gonna happen
here
sorry cakes I'll take 982 re-employed
kingi 797 action makes more sense 85 95
maybe f3 I'm gonna click g5 said I can
plant my knight on e5 here goes b3
Keaney 7 week - how much I'm trying to
win this game at all costs like I don't
know why I don't want to draw on this
game so like most games at least today
it seems like I'm gonna try to do
everything I can to win so let's see
what I can do so I play up 6 teeny 3e 5
looks kind of risky but I'm gonna go for
it which means 6 let's see what he does
Knight b6 I've got rook c6 came out too
so I'm gonna take put all like all my
pawns are on dark squares now as well
which is important it's gonna play H 5 H
4 so yeah I'm just trying to go King c4
and do something here i plays h3 38
it's a water maneuver my king to be six
and once I get my king to be six then
I'm gonna start trying to do something
over here so no no I'm gonna try a five
maybe
no I've got 96 night at 400 now that
I've got their King on b6 and the rooks
doubled now I'm in business so you go c3
so I could take I could also just play
up five maybe I'm gonna play out five
here try to try to really mess it up so
it goes rook e1 so wait but now I can
take not just a pawn and will to rook e8
no I could take I could I'm just gonna
play d4 though I think c6 and now I want
to put the king on d5 and then I'm just
gonna go eat for next me - I could put
III II to me but now I just busted I've
got rook c8 look c3 and it's just
reaching Katie for d3 work Brooksie -
just game over
hmm
d4 hmm interesting maybe 94 Queen c7 see
[Music]
Thank You BGH 13 for the donation sorry
again if you got something a little bit
slow I'm trying to uh trying to trying
to roll the sky so c3 probably he'll
take maybe no he's not gonna take this
looks suspect though like maybe it takes
I can play Knight e4 e5 or something so
it was very slightly suspicious this
looks suspect somehow so II five ninety
five ninety four this looks good
this looks excellent and if there should
be something I've got Knight b5 this is
starting to look good
sorry you said emote someone said what
are emotes are e I don't know what that
action means pardon pardon me
BGH 13th of Sam Copeland streams very
early for us in Los Angeles well I'm
gonna be the Los Angeles soon you guys
so if you guys if you're anywhere near
the Nara near Santa Monica let me know
and I'll maybe I'll come out and stream
from from there at some point
but anyway it's just the thought you
guys just just thought I would mention
it at least why is why is he still
coming on who just resigned here one if
taked I just play Queen d4 or b54 even
just simple simple chaste takes an 84
I'm just digit good good good good
give that f6f for someone says I need to
be in San Francisco on April 7th I'm
gonna be in San Francisco but not on
April 7th that much is for sure
Gigi oh I don't know what Queens this
Queen see don't try anything I just
grabbed the up gg gg
okay efore is this so I'm going to try
to place them I'll play a little more
modern modern seems to be the opening
that's working tonight against this guys
so um do I grab I couldn't play Bishop
d4 what kind of suspect I'll play Bishop
Bishop g4 just keep it simple
I'm sorry someone said PC a finals are
in San Francisco
what are PC a someone want to lighten me
as to what uh I'm sorry what is that
what is the uh sorry PC it what is the
PCL some poker poker championship league
put what is PC I'm the same what is PC
also I'm someone in light because I
clearly don't know
what is PCL ah protests League oh that's
what it is
oh well if we qualify that's good I mean
I better win like every game and have
like a 4000 performance rating or
something or else I don't think it's
gonna happen but yeah maybe if I maybe
if I go like I bet I better win like
every game and have a TPR or 4,000
that's all I'm gonna say
cuz otherwise it's not happening nights
and five it's taking his bishop is much
worse than my knight his bishop is like
blocked in by all these pawns so I
actually think I'm doing quite well here
play a five stop any be for now see five
is a week potentially play 27 clever g8
in c3 now I'm gonna play 9 f8 night h7
and try to kick the rock so please push
buff to correctly now how to activate my
pieces is really the main question I'm
just gonna go back to d7 which still out
for a second please b3 tonight f it I'm
just gonna kind of like loll hunted that
just just make him like fall asleep
somehow
okay so how to convert survey says I
need to put something over on the
queenside probably he just blundered he
just hung eh for now so is he gonna try
to just block hate or how's it gonna do
this because to me Musa brookie hangs h4
she's probably not gonna move the rug so
imma take he's gonna take what da spawn
maybe no it's a rook which is kind of
weird
okay so bishops III on clever b8 now I'm
gonna slowly bring everything over to
the inside
slowly bring my king all the way over to
the inside and then figure it out
although now he missed played it cuz now
he's community for I go community six
and suddenly he's off the diagonal so he
goes Bishop c3 hanging up free pawn
blockade will be destroyed baby your
blockade is no good oh that rookies
seven to work a7 just winning on the
spot but this will win too because you
know right now I'm gonna win any four
and then the house collapses this is not
a draw you guys I'm afraid to tell you
but this is not a draw there is gonna be
a breakthrough okay play something
different I mean this guy just puts his
Bishop on g4 with with no thought of no
thought of the future
okay please work see it so I'll play a
three try to be tricky here I could play
d4 or a complete c5 even but c7 G 2 G 6
I mean I could play E 4 I don't really
love e 4 but I'll go for Bishop f6 ok I
was expecting to play Knight f6 but
anyway it's this pretty classic setup
played a slight edge for white but this
is pretty even in general I'm gonna try
to redeploy my bishops the rights we're
not but if I get d5 then it just
finishes curtains I guess he is e5 kind
of but d6 looks really strong I'm just
gonna go for it he takes if I take is it
GG yo looks like it's another GG e for
WoW but if I take I fail to understand
why block should be okay here so I can
take on I can actually take both I can
take efore with the bishop I can take d6
with the rock-climb I take first and
once it's live got Bishop c4 here but
stuff for or it is pretty simple just
base 6
there should be 5 Queen c6
III I'm just gonna take if I take he
takes Queen d6 and what am I missing
what's maybe I'm still winning here I
mean this is just like this probably is
still winning but like just this isn't
how I wanted to win let's put it that
way
maybe this should be seven ones better
maybe there should be seven instead of
uh gonna be careful here not to blunder
this
this should just be winning king d6 a7
and Bishop f3
but this Scott way closer than to
comfort than I want it I mean this
became much more much more difficult and
I was looking for so now I go a 7
ok 8b 6 and Bishop f3 and king c5 fish
bass 3 GG there should be seven probably
was a lot easier than this but bring my
king I'm one step closer
not that it actually matters but this
this should just be winning okay I don't
have to prove it I will all just promote
get it over with him just
this is just I mean the only difficulty
here is that I have the wrong color
Bishop's so I just have to outflank the
King and bring my king in so you know
it's just winning what's the saying like
I'm just gonna win another game it's
starting to feel like the reaper now so
don't don't fear the reaper
what's it did it um but um come on baby
don't fear the reaper actually though I
made this tricky actually gone King out
for that was pretty obvious
now I've got each four oh did I just
blunder again did I just really just
blunder like that Jesus so freakin
ridiculous so annoying I was so
completely winning if I go King up four
instead of King King D for us so
ridiculously stupid of me it's like
thinking
so anyway let's see what else is going
on you guys
and I of course I'm gonna take he'll
take over 3/7 contrary to popular
opinion I do hate winning winning on
time I mean considering how winning that
position was tough the flag is just like
so so annoying and so disappointing at
the same time so ii v can't i just take
I can take on I can play night beat six
all well no then he takes what does he
father actually thrive does it threaten
anything whatsoever
I play chief for or I take I'm gonna
push page six I'm gonna say what does he
have now I'm gonna say he has absolutely
Scottish so eleven true V at says if
you're going to San Fran that would be
awesome naka I mean I am gonna be in San
Francisco in the near future probably in
early March so that's all that I'm gonna
say right now but it's I'm gonna be in
San Francisco you guys so it's not like
I'm just like spouting off and they're
just wondering right c7 oh no they're
just wondering hc7
but I can take and play about
three or something like so ridiculously
bad it's like super bad
super super bad I'm all try to win this
I don't even know why I'm trying to win
this but I try to play on for some
stupid unknown reason
so ridiculously bad I just did in the
scheme there's no reason to play g4 when
I work c6 was completely fine King h1
okay so you please King h1 like mean d8
maybe there's my 7 king weight weensy
six been talked about 97 all right Queen
g5 maybe Wow
okay Queenie six Queen b6 so he's just
he's just grabbing he thinks he's
completely just like fine here which he
probably is but a mica like Knight a5
deewan I mean it's just so miserable
what did I do to my position
maybe Queen b6 trying to try for some
Queens off the ward like yeah and
actually someone asked what it's
Scandinavian chess that's a Swedish
trust so that's basically just bughouse
but we're more Americans so we don't
actually know that
d1 maybe knight c6 I mean I don't know
why he changed Queens there's literally
no need to exchange the Queens but man
wants to it's a free world he can do
whatever he wants to do I don't know why
he did that but that made next to no
sense to me
Bishop g7 maybe 494 evening
wait 94 wiki 8 just calm down b7
maybe just like try to h4 it just takes
each horse oddly a terrible move by him
I mean just like ruined his position for
no reason now I trapped his own rook
I've got rook e8 though but it's still
completely lost maybe a six yeah
pretty busted I'm just gonna play
something where we get this line
mission tree force slightly dubious
queen h5 really what is this
someone just had a dollop it yeah yeah I
don't think I've won 10 in a row
actually but but I am definitely trying
I mean if I go defy what why can't I go
94 here thanks man
but wait whoa whoa what free exchange
for speech to king h1 I cover the pond
okay so he's clearly cracking now if
he's just gonna blunder like that
tonight a fork
tape would be ballsy I don't have to but
I want I'm gonna be greedy play like a
computer because computers actually play
good shots I'm like us humans I'm gonna
say g3 maybe night h3 kingi - I know I'm
not ready to say GG yo it's still is
still going on game is not over yet it's
gonna play work b3 - hit - hit him with
Fishbach three but also the rook on be
through protects the pawn on g3 so
they're known I teach three night off -
Sox either tonight it's fine oh I just
go bitched about three GGO gg gg
all right so yeah so I beat him to get
back over 3,000 but now I want to play
someone else let's find someone that
someone else to play yes I am Rosen okay
you guys I'm going to try to play some
bowling I'm not gonna be commenting but
let's see if I can actually play ball
without lagging and losing doesn't look
like it but maybe not maybe he's lagging
maybe it's not me what did I just do
really just blunder like that wait am i
lying there's HELOC I thought I thought
it was me lying
maybe actually it's just him lying so
never mind see you know what you guys
I'm gonna try my place in Bowl let's see
if I can do this without like lagging
insanely to the point where like I can't
play
boys are mistakes in a queen e85 truck
it's already another GG yo so apparently
I'm not lagging I mean I assumed it and
I'm good you guys are guys still hearing
me I'm still like completely like
playing it oh I guess I guess yeah you
know if you know I've tried bullet
before number work but it's like if I if
I can actually do this like it's pretty
awesome if I'm not lagging but we'll see
so far so good action I'm actually not
lagging which is amazing so every time I
try bullet in the past it never works
out wall
literally every time in the past I tried
to try to play bullet I've been lagging
that crazy so it's pretty awesome I'm
not gonna lag and I'm just gonna play
more and more Bowl you guys this is like
this is the dream eric is good but he's
not he's not oh this is awesome you guys
oh this is awesome
oh man if I can just play bullet without
any lag Oh
but I just wonder that don't worry
that's annoying
oh boy he had our queen Cakes d3 and I
was totally cooked and he missed it
game continues game continues yeah baby
come on I'm gonna go for adoption
against Erick if I can assuming that I
don't want lag and just like lose the
stupid game
I'm sorry I see someone donated or said
something but I'm like I'm like hitting
my groove right now so I can't can't say
thank you sorry sorry - whoever donated
just like trying to Zone in now so this
is uh this this really is a dream if I
can play bullet with no alive and it's
like Mamma Mia
rook c24 the save and now rookie to and
I protect all my pawns and now I just
win oh yeah
come on Eric you gotta move faster man
I mean I had night c2 of course but I
mean he's he's completely baked anyway
so it's like doesn't does an accident
matter cooking eh it just sidestep any
tricks as Bishop g5 and what is 94 now
I've got Queen a5 and night f7 I just
take I'm threatening made on 81 and 82
Mamma Mia another one yes time to adopt
him I feel like seeing it mommy a song
it's like Mamma Mia here we go again my
my how I can truly ryx whatever this is
bullet I don't have time for lyrics oh
this came up myself and go back
and here go the pawns yeah it's like
flexing here comes the song does it do
do it comes a son I say it's alright
okay so Eric's trying to create some
threats this game so I gave him King g3
yikes totally unnecessary given King g3
and ArcheAge one totally unnecessary
Chuck free Queen baby free Queen King g8
and now is just his baked a gun he's got
nothing
I see some of the chances that I'm
covering the beetles thump I'm sorry
that's that's not that's not my
intention I'm not uh not even one one
one-hundredth as good as they are
okay I can't trip Queens cuz then I've
got problems he's about night-night five
that's a slight slightly annoying but
I'm still up ten seconds so it's gonna
be good it's all gonna work out wait
there's there's not a threat so I just
kick his queen so age 324 ah now for
baby oh he's got clean eh five annoying
nasty very very annoying what free night
free pond one check no meat GGO gg all
right rock and roll rock and roll
free rook free cheque free night okay so
yeah that that's hen so I just uh
ooh nice nice nice nice ten in a row
awesome adoption alright that was a
little bit too exciting I'm gonna play
some place some blitz again if I can oh
that's awesome if I if I can play polo
with no laughs yeah I'm just gonna put
like bullet and nothing else
thank you Shawn was a bad dot dot dot
for the donation yeah like you guys have
no idea that's like I mean it's just
like the best thing ever because like I
could never play bullet due to the lag
but if there's no lag man I'm just gonna
play bullet all day long that's like the
best thing ever it's like just like
seriously the best thing ever there's
like nothing better in the world so okay
let's see is there anyone else on or am
i okay fine you know I'm just gonna
resort to just punishing the other Erica
and someone just donated I don't know
who like major oddball I think it was or
something like that
now he's gonna Castle I'm gonna go g4
and he's gonna drop a piece ooh
Bishop to e3 he's improving he sees he's
singing same tricks better now but Vista
G through his terrible move does now
when he goes 94 I go d3 and I could just
pick up two pieces for a rook or Knight
up to I maybe go Queen d2 even I'm just
gonna go Queen d2 exciton I don't see
how he saves it takes and okay
and he's already down like 30 seconds
like it's just insane I mean he's got
like and I've got night f7 with his
family for coming
oh man this is just brutal Bishop c5 d 4
this is disgusting and Bishop c5 d 4
Queen g3 Queen G 2 just another gg ah
improved you saw what I was doing
improved that's very annoying oh oh
slightly a problematic takes to a
Queenie one I do but I'm just gonna take
the big castle just try it try try to
play like decent some of decent moves
here since I'm down up down upon but I'm
already probably like I'm already only
like slightly worse as is so it's like
becoming very very good alright a for GG
yo GG tech mate checkmate in one baby
free rock baby come on
now chief or get rid of his bishops
what's this I can keep I didn't have to
take og5 oh yeah yeah a clean chief I've
just Gigi oh that's very ridiculously
bad of me how do I seek when take g5
Rose Chuck free peace free pawn the
Queen d5 Knight f3 I guess it's all so
beautiful now I've got everything going
for me in this game
g3 economically e5 and e6 and sorry you
guys I didn't see whoever is donating to
me I sorry sorry guys I'm just I'm
playing ball and I can't can't spot
everything now and his bishops kind of
trap has got a Chi 795 turning the fork
and here comes the fork
and I'm just gonna take the free piece
these pieces are better than exchanges
take some bonds 586 494 probably Oh
night see one play p45 I'm gonna play a
five I don't know five five is good or
not but seems like a reasonable choice
of anything
he's got 85 95
tick tock tick tock goes the clock baby
he got a move
ah he's got a good move but he gave up
like so much time the process of doing
that they're like he needs a lot of uh
there's three fork fork baby fork town
free Queen dot dot dot
but I'm put on throw my e I just give
him a fork
fork baby
butter butter but I'm gonna bum now 95
in 93 is coming this is gonna get ugly
as well 5.6 as a move and I can just
feel like Queenie 7 there's gonna be
really quite ugly
nice III Queen c6 or peen a six time
everything is pretty bad for white at
this point though Burke c3 now I've got
rookie three tricks all over the place
clean b7 I just exchanged for K to just
kind of more GG e 4e to eat d3
everything's kind of loose here I can
just play with me too with some oh no
I'm gonna mix it up I'm gonna take with
the Queen this time or is gonna flavor
let's see so you please I'm gonna offer
an exchange of Bishops here try to
simplify ever so slightly so we'll see
threatened it's got no actual threat so
I'm going to slow it down a little bit
play it like a swan if he takes I'll
take it tonight
chief taking play off six do I
ignite a fire I guess I maybe I do
whoa now I check I just pick up another
pawn nice moves Knight takes c6 Queen g3
if he takes I think with a pawn if he
doesn't I go d3 in his queen is trapped
GGO next game nice you for probably five
I'll take 497 play out five probably
he'll take I'll take maybe with the pawn
maybe not
ah
daddy's blender at one exchange oh well
life goes on you can't win them all
oh okay I just wonder something oh this
has gotten way too close for comfort I'm
still probably I'm still probably gonna
win on time okay but now I just play
like work takes b4 and what's he doing I
just start taking all his pawns and but
boom double adoption baby oh yeah uh all
right you guys all right
ah that was good that was good yeah
there's no lag now it's just gonna be
like amazing so I know someone someone
donated or something or subscribed I I
didn't actually see that earlier you
guys sorry about that yeah so that was
pretty pretty awesome see so who else is
around play with
okay I play some more blitz again after
putting all that bullet it's like blitz
think it seemed like boom boom boom boom
and it's like wait I still 2 minutes
left okay
v6 interesting
Queeny an interesting choice so he wants
to place c5 I presume 12 play 96 eyes
got c5 so okay so Queen it's calm enough
to take take and then or wait what to
eat soon 94 does he just have to see
before in like see before 98 98 95
I have compensation but this is not
really what I was aiming for it to start
so although he just took what the effort
which was wrong because now I've got
fork fork things coming so takes rook c5
Bishop d2 maybe I'm probably slightly
worse but I can't be much worse here be
my guess whoa 95 let's see one movie and
free peace baby free peace ah this guy
wants to play like me okay I'll play
weird stuff I'll play Knight intersects
like Magnus we need you for d5 put each
five let's let's try like attack
although each photo is probably a bad
news because about four here just east
6c 5 something standard should be force
also move
wait now I can take one g3 96 maybe
right before she probably got to playing
all that bullet now that's like I'm just
moving way too fast we're just like
playing this like it's like I don't know
it's like it's like bullet basically an
85 maybe between squee knife to c4
now this is blitz this is blitz time to
chill and find good moves good moves
nothing but good news i'm gonna play b5
and go for c4 c3 just like true caveman
style just like all in just go for me
night a3 okay caveman caveman I plead b5
stop god I've got us - I've got to stay
true to what I'm playing so I'm going
gonna go for it
before okay I got it I got to stay true
to it I've got to go for it
whoa whoa whoa DC for what fish created
three to cd5 I refuse to believe that Y
can possibly be okay here after ten
except it takes takes Chuck c1 Chuck
King to 296 maybe this is wrong I mean
I'm just playing too fast probably
probably just work seeing an 84 is more
appropriate okay take on c2
look see one and I can go 94 cuz I
between d4 would see 825 92 I'm I missed
for about 30 at 92 here so I'm just kind
of liberal CA Thanks
take 5 maybe a queen bee 6 but he's got
94 I'm slightly wrong this is kind of
terrible what am I doing here too much
bull and I was like playing way too fast
some way
yeah it's just just playing way too fast
out of nowhere it's like just playing
much too fast I need to slow it down a
little bit now yeah it's much play it
playing way too fast
it's like blitzing everything is just
moving much too fast so it's next game
where is he is he gonna run away
seriously after two games now for two
games is gonna run away seriously okay
fine I'll play Buffy let's see more
interesting at least 593 694
I kind of blundered that actually I
didn't mean to allow this but I think
having allowed this let's see if I can
somehow survive or do something complete
for maybe still play much too fast but
let's see what he wants to do here so 97
can play e5 play 92 also I could play
I'm gonna play e5 just to close the long
diagonal down and also I created square
for my knight on e4 as well can you be
six like I played 94 94 actually makes a
lot of Suns here takes I could take what
the pawn I'll take with a bishop here
just keep my pawn structure intact g5 is
hanging out as well
just gonna start rolling my pawns right
up the board now got a six huge and I
just wonder that I'm not good I actually
blundered that that concept I could play
each six though he should have taken him
and played ninety-seven because now I
know G five is perfect it covers the e4
and just go king f2 and rook e1 and just
terrible for Block B six play b3 cover
this e4 square coz he's still trying to
get his Knight to e4 if he can but a
little bit late
hey you play dragon like I played
earlier on the approach how sleek so you
have to do I want to play this one okay
see what he wants playing like 92 or
something or chess process next time
next time what what does next time
supposed to mean what does next time
supposed to mean
it's my local Bishop e6 just protect
everything and queens u5 I'll play
Knight d7 just to protect the e5 whoa
Knight c1 wow that's that's really kind
of asking for it so I'm gonna I'm just
gonna go all-in c4 Queen c3 c4 I'm just
trying to meet him straight up chest bra
I'm in Halifax
otherwise it'd mop up your rating well I
mean what's in Halifax exactly I mean is
that for real is he really in Halifax
what's he doing is he it like doll house
II or something that's very very random
that uh Eric would be in a would be in
um would be in Halifax that's just very
very rarely
you can't be serious you guys is they
are really in Halifax that's like so
very very random if he really is in
Halifax
okay so Queen g5 so he's trying to sum I
bill he wants to take on e5 but go 90 70
a lot he is Queenie 7 though I guess I
guess that's this point I can play rook
e8 maybe maybe rookie it just makes
sense because Queenie father got there
should be three with the discovery on
the Queen someone says what does doll
housing mean there is a university in um
in in Halifax
called doll house d dl Hou SI e so so
that that might be why Eric is there
that's that's what I was referring to D
3 all in just time to attack someone
said do I do not think of a trash talk I
mean I only like trash talking Eric
because Eric totally deserves it
free piece fork like a cake a clean at
age five a lot of options here for me
she resigns okay so um well playing I
guess I'll play something similar what
we have last game
[Music]
efore interesting okay so please efore
well sure what he wants to lock it up or
click f4 play something really weird the
probably is bad but I don't understand
why it's bad
ladies 6-piston all play this would be
to page six nine th three so you go see
five so I'll click me to to currently
missing a child I'm sure Eric is saying
something in the chat but I'm missing it
apparently
did Eric really go one out of eight
tonight if he did that's like I mean
that's not the worst things worst things
ever I really hope that's not true
Eirik what 1 out of 8 wow that's that's
not good man that's not good isn't there
there's what that that uh feels bad man
isn't that it's not the saying I forget
how it goes
feels bad man
so work be sick so I can play 96 I'm
just gonna play Bishop c3 the idea of
Bishop a5 possibly also idea of queen
bee - maybe something along the diet or
sorry wrong diagonal be to 288 maybe h6
logical night h3 maybe Bishop a4 a5 made
sense there are actually but just gonna
keep keep consolidate and bring my
Knights back or better squares b8 work
a3 just protect the pawn on c3 um be 396
I could take and play rook a one maybe
all that I'm saying b3 I did but he
missed it he had rook takes beats where
and where takes the e3 there but play 91
and now again I'm consolidating like
everything's starting to get the sign-up
b4 in fact is really terrible because
it's got no squares and in a way it
stops the works from attacking the pawn
on b3 so before I'm just gonna play King
King f1 just calm and relaxed and I'll
try to exchange the rooks 17 you can
play ok 781 calm and relaxed I have six
per speech three maybe there's some
tricks here like fish about five maybe
probably Dan all-star quite a hot he's
gonna have to take also I can take all
the pawns on me win here
- to candy 294 pigs probably take stakes
or 993 c5 xe5 I mean it's a lot of pawns
for that I have so uh all right you guys
another went back to 3,000 that's where
I was like four hours ago or something
so um yeah yeah all right you guys I
think I'm I think that's good for now
I think I think I'm probably gonna stop
so and anywhere I hope you guys enjoyed
the show tonight especially because I
tried to make it more entertaining I was
able I was able to play bullet for a
change which is just like I mean I know
I know I said it was exciting was
excellent but you guys really have no
idea when like you can't play bullet
when you're streaming and now I can it's
like it's it's really the greatest thing
ever so hopefully I'll stream some more
some more bullet for sure it I mean
assuming no lie I mean it's just great
so at any rate all right you guys so I'm
gonna call it a night and I might be
back tomorrow since I have one more day
before I head to Russia so by at OMA
I'll come back tomorrow but I'll
definitely definitely be around more
more in the next month or so since I'm
starting to get back in the streaming so
until next time you guys have a good
evening alright